67 would be seven  yeah and it's probably  just fine and being one yeah okay so he  even collected more material by which  I'm not taking on F2 and oh language  page three this is nasty this is more  more material to  to be won immediately  nice very nice game by biting uh  yeah absolutely and not an easy one  because he didn't play since the last  candidates uh we don't know how much uh  I guess he was training quite a lot but  it's never the same and you play a  youngster in the first round which  educated somehow that he had uh yeah I  think I think you had the right idea  from the beginning yeah that he just he  just wanted to put a position on the  board where